ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TRYING TO
SMUGGLE MARIJUANA INTO THE US.
KEN CUCCINELLI JOINS US NOW.
IT IS A SAD STORY TO TALK ABOUT
A 4-YEAR-OLD FOUND AMONG
SMUGGLERS.
WISE THE HAPPENING?
>> IT IS A SAD STORY BUT THIS
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
THE ROOTS THE CARTELS USE AND
REMEMBER WHO MANAGES THE BORDER,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THE DRUG CARTELS
OF MEXICO, THE SOME OF THE MOST
EVIL VICIOUS PEOPLE IN THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE AND THEIR
HUMAN SMUGGLING OPERATION
THROUGH THE SAME CHANNELS AS
THEIR DRUG SMUGGLING OPERATIONS
AND THEY DIRECT THE FLOWS TO
DISTRACT AND MOVE THE BORDER
PATROL AROUND USING PEOPLE TO
AVOID GETTING THEIR HIGH-VALUE
CROSSINGS CAUGHT AND TO PUT AS
MANY OF THEM OVER THE BORDER AS
POSSIBLE, THERE ARE ESTIMATES
THE DRUG CARTELS ARE MAKING MORE
MONEY FROM HUMAN SMUGGLING THAN
DRUG SMUGGLING AND NO ONE,
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR STATE
INCLUDING TEXAS IS DOING
ANYTHING TO STOP THAT FLOW.
WILL: LET'S DISCUSS TEXAS,
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT EMBARKED ON
A CAMPAIGN TO SEND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO WASHINGTON DC.
A THIRD BUS HAS ARRIVED IN
WASHINGTON DC TO ESSENTIALLY LAY
THE PROBLEM AT THE FEET OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
PROGRAM?
>> IT IS THE LAST LEG IN THE
HUMAN SMUGGLING CHAIN, THE
RECENT ARTICLES ABOUT RENEWING
CHARTER FLIGHTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY OF ILLEGALS FARTHER IN
AND NOW TEXAS IS DOING IT.
I UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WANT TO
DROP THEM IN THE STEPS OF THE
CAPITAL BUT THESE ARE VOLUNTARY
TRIPS, THEY WANT TO TAKE THE
TRIP.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS PAYING TO
BOSTON 26 HOURS ON A TRIP THEY
WANT TO TAKE.
INSTEAD OF BUSSING THEM TO MILES
BACK ACROSS THE MEXICAN BORDER
WHICH IS WHAT HE SHOULD BE DOING
AND UNTIL HE DOES THAT, THAT MAY
BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS, AND HE DOES
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO REMOVE
PEOPLE FROM MEXICO TO MEXICO,
THE ILLEGAL FLOW WILL NOT GO
DOWN.
FOR ALL THE SIGNING WITH MEXICAN
STATE GOVERNORS WHO DON'T HAVE
ANY AUTHORITY TO STOP
IMMIGRATION ACROSS THE BORDER IT
IS ALL A SHOW AND YOU WILL SEE
NEXT MONTH WHEN THE NUMBERS COME
OUT BEFORE TITLE 42 IS TAKEN
DOWN ON MAY 23RD IT HAS NO
EFFECT ON THE FLOW OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
PETE: I CAN HEAR YOU ARE LAYING
BLAME NOT JUST AT THE FEET OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT ON
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS, GREG
ABBOTT, YOU ARE SAYING THIS IS
ALL POLITICAL THEATER.
I HAVE HAD ON "FOX AND FRIENDS"
LAST WEEKEND KEN PAXTON AND
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK
ON THE PROGRAM AND I ASKED THEM
ABOUT YOUR ACCUSATION BEFORE IT
WAS MADE THAT THIS IS POLITICAL
THEATER AND BOTH OF THEIR
RESPONSE IS THE POINT IS TO
FORCE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CONFRONTATION, TO FORCE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO CONFRONT
THE FACT THEY ARE NOT ENFORCING
OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS SOAR TEXAS
OR SOMEONE MUST.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING AND I WANT
TO GET YOUR RESPONSE, THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO SUPPORT FORCE IT TO
THE SUPREME COURT ON WHO CAN
ENFORCE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
>> KEN PAXTON AND DAN PATRICK
KNOW HOW TO DO THAT.
ISN'T BUSSING PEOPLE TO
WASHINGTON.
IT IS BY THE GOVERNOR AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF OF TEXAS
FORCES, EVERY GOVERNOR IS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF OF THEIR OWN
STATES FORCES STOPPING THE
INVASION, GREG ABBOTT CALLING IT
AN INVASION AND I DON'T THINK
MANY PEOPLE WOULD DISPUTE THAT
IS WHAT IS GOING ON AND
REPELLING THAT UNDER ARTICLE 1
SECTION 10 OF THE CONSTITUTION.
IF YOU WANT TO PROVOKE A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS MAYBE YOU
SHOULD USE YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY TO DO IT INSTEAD OF A
BUNCH OF PRESS GIMMICKS.
NOT JUST GOVERNOR ABBOTT, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT TEXAS, BUT
GOVERNOR DOOCY IN ARIZONA AND
HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS FOUND
HE HAS THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO DO
THIS SO THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
WAY AND HIS STATE FROM ACTING TO
DEFEND THE BORDERS OF THEIR
STATE AND THE UNITED STATES.
PETE: YOU COULD DO THE SAME
THING BY REMOVING THEM BACK TO
MEXICO INSTEAD OF TO WASHINGTON.
GREAT CONVERSATION, GREAT
PERSPECTIVE AND PERHAPS WE WIL